it baffles me how many people think that
they're bigger than they actually are
I hear people say like well how do I get
into New York Times or or how do I get
that meeting with that CEO and
oftentimes I just say one is better than
zero
the steps it takes to actually get to
the biggest places in the world before
you get a meeting with you know Luxor or
Cuban or Barry Diller or whatever you're
trying to have a meeting with in the
business world well you've got to have a
lot of little meetings that to build up
your cadence people always like man
you've been on Conan at an Ellen and the
Today Show and CNN and Fox like how do I
get that and I'm like well I also did a
thousand interviews it feels like on
videos that got 1 or 19 or 137 news my
PR people like managers and handlers are
really pissed at me because I'm like why
are you spending 15 minutes doing these
blogs that have six feeders you know
every single day and you're passing on
the stuff that we're giving you to be on
CNN or year five I still even today I'm
as happy and sometimes even more excited
to be on a podcast or video blog that's
only gonna reach a hundred people
because I'm always about depth versus
with do you want why do you want to go
deep I want the people in my community I
want to give that to people that were
fans of me and so even today where I
have more leverage than I did three or
four or five six years ago to get bigger
platforms I still live under the model
of one is better than zero to me doing
these interviews is a process of the
work that so many people are impatient
and not willing to do are you willing to
take ten minutes to get 195 years I am I
don't know who you think you are you've
not gotten the exposure yet when you
have not made your lean just yet when
you're still making the climb when
you're not paying attention because
nobody else is because 217 people watch
the video I'm grinding when you're
sleeping I did those 87 s and 59 s of
137 s and 813 views day in and day out
day in and day out day in and day out
and continue to you may make a video on
somebody's video show that has 89
viewers but one of those 89 viewers may
be a producer at CNN or or might be the
CFO of a big company that you're trying
to reach and so undervaluing just that
one view needs to be the right you but
it's one view is a humongous mistake
it's about having the humility it's
about not saying
when you've made it and the one is
greater than zero concept is something
I'm proud that I continue to execute on